oui aussi un petit netbook wind in the
wall
c'était la conjointe de david saint
jacques les astronautes qui parlait avec
nos collègues de cilicie alors une
espèce de camp spatial qui s'en vient
pour toute la famille une quarantaine
dans laquelle david saint jacques sera
placée après son retour sur terre après
avoir passé deux cent quatre jours dans
l'espace doit se réhabituer à la gravité
parce qu'évidemment il flottait à
l'intérieur de la station spatiale au
cours des derniers mois je repars avec
olivier hernandez il est du planétarium
rio tinto monsieur hernandez bonsoir
bonsoir
voici ce que david saint jacques à dit
juste après à être descendus de la
capsule qui l'a ramené chez toi ça va ça
sent l'essence était on est retombé le
ciel terreau allemands tombés du ciel
une fois une fois qu on se convainc que
c'est pas dangereux
mais d'abord nous sommes chanceux d'être
venu nous sommes plus nous et eux puis
mais je suis suisse qui me surprend
c'est l'odeur du foin ici c'est super
bon baromètre opinionway
alors david saint jacques était malade
en revenant il doit réapprendre à fond à
marcher aussi monsieur hernanes est ce
que c'est normal là ce qui lui arrive au
bout c'est tout à fait normal en fait
tous les symptômes qu'il a eu son total
totalement attendu en fait on pourrait
se mettre à sa place facilement il
suffirait de prendre une photo de nous
d'avoir des journalistes à la sortie
d'un manège de la ronde et puis on vire
à peu près la face honorer ce serait
vraiment surprenant on aura à peu près
là le même état de fatigue et puis on
serait blanc si on est sensible à ce
genre de choses là il se trouve qu'il a
été sensible
après cette chute vertigineuse de la
ramener sur terre mais c'est tout à fait
normal parce que ce qui nous a étonnés
un but c'est que les commandants qui est
sorti en premier était un peu blême vous
redire mais sa collègue était très
énergique comme si elle avait vraiment
aimé une manège oui bah en fait ça
dépend de la physionomie de la génétique
des personnes c'est un peu pareil comme
le mal d'altitude lorsqu'on va dans les
montagnes des gens qui sont affectés
d'autres mois puis ça dépend pas du tout
de la config condition physique donc
c'est ce qui lui est arrivé là tu sais
c'est bénin ça va passer en fait ça
ressemble à quoi est-ce parce que c'est
pas gros à la capsule soyouz la cession
pour 3 personnes
on appelle ça en fait la machine à laver
ça donne une bonne image sale image ça
ressemble à un gros fardeau tôt avec une
une grosse entrée de machines à laver
donc les gens sont dedans et puisse
embrasser dans fait durant la descente
qui dure quelques minutes en fait et
puis ils doivent passer à une vitesse de
28 mille kilomètres heure quand même
jusqu'à une vitesse de zéro parce qu'ils
atterrissent sur le sol donc ça ça en
arrivant en fait en arrivant juste en
arrivant ici ont une vitesse environ 2
25 km/heure et puis à un mètre du sol
mais vraiment un m il ya six rétrofusées
qui partent orties pour amortir le choc
de la capsule et puis qui leur permet en
fait de d'absorber un peu chocs mais
mais quand même les photos ils me sont
montées sur des amortisseurs et puis le
l'expérience n'est pas très bonne ils
ont l'habitude de dire que c'est c'est
comme si c'était un accident entre une
petite auto et un camion le petites
autos étant la capsule bien sûr et pas
un camion d'accord donc qu'est-ce qui
atteint david saint-jacques parce que sa
conjointe il nous dit on va aller en
quarantaine avec lui il va être sous
d'observation en juillet d'une ville
avait beaucoup de difficultés à marcher
oui qu'est-ce qui se passe le poids de
la gravité énorme c'est pour ça qu'il
disait que la gravité n'était pas son
ami et ça va encore durer quelques
quelques semaines comme ça ça va peut
être son ami quelques semaines mais
après il va reprendre tranquillement ses
sensations vis-à-vis de la gravité alors
il va subir une batterie de tests aussi
ça reste un cobaye jeu mais cobayes
entre guillemets bien sûr médicale il se
prête volontiers à ce genre d'expérience
là parce que en fait on n'a pas beaucoup
d'astronautes qui ont été dans l'espace
et qui sont revenus et on a besoin
d'avoir beaucoup de données
scientifiques pour prouve pour savoir
exactement quels sont les effets de la
gravitation de la gravité sur le corps
des astronautes pour faire des voyages
qui seront beaucoup plus grands comme
par exemple aller sur mars qui
nécessitent des durées beaucoup plus
grand de deux ans trois ans fait donc il
va servir en fait de cobayes de on va
récolter tout un tas d'informations de
mesures qui ont été prises avant le
départ pendant la mission et après son
arrivée d'ailleurs même dans le vol qui
l'a ramené le goal normal d'avion il a
déjà commencé à travailler
oui tout à fait en fait on a testé ses
capacités à actionner
sur un simulateur le bras canadien donc
avec une petite expérience qui appelle
au vote et ont l'avantagé c'est tout à
fait la démarche scientifique est
illustrée par ce qu'on l'a fait faire
avant de partir on lui avait on a fait
faire l'expérience pendant la mission
puis maintenant on juste après la
mission on essaye de voir quelles sont
ses réflexes c'est sa façon de ce corps
dit coordonnées donc c'est un peu tout
ça qu'on essaye de tester ça a quelque
chose à voir avec l'oreille interne si
c'est l'oreille interne qui fait en
sorte que leur on est de l'equilibre
qu'on est capable c'est loris et
l'oreille interne qui va vous permettre
de contrôler correctement l'équilibré
puis on n'est pas très gentil avec les
astronautes parce que on joue beaucoup
avec l'oreille interne on les envoie de
la terre dans l'espace dont ils ont un
premier mal de terre ou mal en arrivant
dans l'espace puis après ils ont un
autre mal de l'espace quand ils
reviennent sur terre on re perturbent
leur lorientais dans l'espace en
apesanteur c'est comme s'il ya des
branchements qui se fait tout à fait ça
prend quelques jours et puis sont
complètement débranché il arrive à
s'habituer en fait à la situation de
flottement qui se passe avec +2 au plus
de bas et leurs corps s'habitue c'est
très délicat parce qu'au début on
pourrait avoir l'impression que le
malaise va être permanent mais
finalement le corps s'habitue à ces
situations là et puis c'est ce qui va
lui permettre lui aussi en revenant sur
terre d'avoir cette même semaine
changement le corps va se réhabituer
tranquillement
à cette situation malgré ses difficultés
à renan le corps est une machine
extraordinaire ex madame qui s'adapte et
sur l'environnent cette adaptation là
qu'on cherche à comprendre c'est
absolument fascinant d'ailleurs il y
avait plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes hier choix qui regardait son
arrivée avec we brothers le choix oui
tout à fait le journée saint jean ouais
vous le faire pour le faire richert d'un
dess merci beaucoup merci bonne soirée